vítej zpět u seriálu Pochopení kvantové informace a výpočtů, jmenuji se John Watrous a jsem technický ředitel pro vzdělávání v IBM
Quantum – toto je 16. a poslední lekce série a tématem lekce jsou výpočty odolné vůči chybám
v průběhu předchozích tří lekcí jsme viděli několik příkladů kvantových kódů opravujících chyby, které mohou detekovat a umožnit nám
opravit kvantové chyby, pokud jich není příliš mnoho – pokud ale chceme využít opravu chyb pro kvantové výpočty, stále existuje mnoho
otázek, se kterými se musíme vypořádat, včetně reality, že naše kvantové gates, měření a přípravy stavů
budou samy pravděpodobně nedokonalé – takže například, pokud budeme provádět opravu chyb na jednom
nebo více qubitech zakódovaných pomocí kvantového kódu opravujícího chyby, budeme to muset dělat gates a měřeními, která sama
mají šanci nefungovat správně – a to znamená nejen selhání detekce nebo opravy chyb, ale případně
i zavádění nových chyb – kromě toho musíme také provádět skutečné výpočty, o které máme zájem, opět s gates, které nejsou
dokonalé – a rozhodně nemůžeme riskovat dekódování kvantové informace kvůli provádění výpočtů a pak
opětovné kódování, jakmile jsme hotovi, protože chyby by mohly zasáhnout, když chybí ochrana kvantového kódu opravujícího chyby
to znamená, že musíme přijít na to, jak provádět kvantové gates přímo na logických qubitech, které nikdy nejsou bez
ochrany kvantového kódu opravujícího chyby – to je nelehký úkol, ale je known, že dokud hladina šumu
nepřekročí určitou prahovou hodnotu, je ve skutečnosti možné provádět libovolně velké kvantové výpočty spolehlivě pomocí hlučného hardwaru, přinejmenším
teoreticky – a tento kriticky důležitý fakt probereme později v lekci – tady je stručný přehled
lekce – začneme základním modelem pro výpočty odolné vůči chybám, včetně stručné diskuse
o modelech šumu spolu s obecnou metodologií pro implementaci kvantového circuitu odolně
vůči chybám – pak přejdeme k otázce šíření chyb v kvantových circuitech odolných vůči chybám a jak ho
řídit – konkrétně budu hovořit o transversálních implementacích gates, které nabízejí velmi jednoduchý způsob řízení šíření chyb,
ačkoli existuje zásadní omezení, které nám brání používat tuto metodu
výhradně – budu také hovořit o jiné metodologii zahrnující tzv. magické stavy, která nabízí jiný přístup k řízení šíření chyb
v kvantových circuitech odolných vůči chybám, ačkoli to není jediná known metoda, a nakonec lekce
zakončí poměrně obecnou diskusí o větu o prahu, na který jsem před chvílí narážel
tato věta říká, že libovolně velké kvantové circuity mohou být implementovány spolehlivě, pokud chybovost všech komponent
je pod určitou konečnou prahovou hodnotou – obecně tato prahová hodnota
závisí na kódu opravujícím chyby, který používáme, i na konkrétních volbách, které provádíme pro odolné implementace
kvantových gates a měření, nikoli na velikosti implementovaného circuitu – a to nám dává dobrý důvod věřit, že rozsáhlé
kvantové výpočty se jednou stanou realitou – začneme diskusí o základním modelu pro výpočty odolné vůči chybám
které jsou přirozeně founded na kvantových circuitech a kvantových kódech opravujících chyby – pro účely této diskuse
si představme, že máme kvantový circuit, který chceme implementovat, například ten zobrazený zde – tato náhoda
je teleportační circuit včetně přípravy EBIT – ale specifika pro tuto diskusi nezáleží – a mohl bys si představit, že
to je jakýkoli jiný kvantový circuit, možná mnohem větší circuit zahrnující přípravy stavů, unitární
operace a měření – tento circuit samozřejmě reprezentuje ideál a skutečná
implementace nebude dokonalá – přirozenou otázkou, kterou si klást, je, co by mohlo jít
špatně – no, může jít špatně dost věcí – například inicializace stavů obecně nebudou
dokonalé – samozřejmě unitární gates nebudou dokonalé a ani
měření nebudou – a navíc samy qubity budou náchylné k šumu, včetně dekoherence, v každém bodě
výpočtu, i když se s těmito qubity nic neděje a jednoduše uchovávají kvantovou informaci – jinými slovy, prakticky
všechno by mohlo jít špatně – existuje ale jedna výjimka, nebo přinejmenším jde o typický předpoklad, a
sice že jakékoli klasické výpočty, které jsou zahrnuty, pravděpodobně nebudou chybné, protože de facto
jsou klasické výpočty v podstatě dokonalé – takže například, pokud spustíme klasický párovací algoritmus pro
výpočet oprav pro chyby povrchového kódu, opravdu se nemusíme obávat, že by tento klasický výpočet mohl být chybný – ale cokoli, co přímo
zahrnuje kvantovou informaci, by chybné být mohlo – samozřejmě potřebujeme přesný model, pomocí kterého přiřadíme
pravděpodobnosti různým chybám – a pokud bychom chtěli, mohli bychom přijít s tak složitým modelem, jak chceme, abychom snad odráželi, co
se skutečně děje v realitě – pokud je ale model příliš složitý, mohl by se ukázat jako obtížný nebo nemožný k práci nebo k říkání
čehokoli zajímavého – jeden velmi jednoduchý příklad modelu šumu, který lidé často uvažují,
je model nezávislého stochastického šumu, kde chyby nebo poruchy postihující různé komponenty v různých
okamžicích, neboli na různých místech v circuitu, jsou nezávislé
například bychom mohli říct, že každý gate selže s určitou pravděpodobností, že bit flipy a phase flipy nastávají na uložených qubitech s jinou
pravděpodobností za jednotku času a podobně – ale předpokladem je, že mezi různými
chybami není žádná korelace – nyní bys mohl namítnout tomuto modelu, protože pravděpodobně budou určité korelace mezi
chybami – například pravděpodobně existuje malá šance katastrofické chyby, která naráz zničí všechny qubity
nebo, možná pravděpodobněji, by mohlo dojít k lokalizovaným chybám, které přesto postihnou více komponent
a nikdo neříká opak – přesto však tento model představuje jednoduchý základ, který
v podstatě reprezentuje myšlenku, že příroda je nepředvídatelná, ale není zákeřná a nesnaží se záměrně
ničit kvantové výpočty – existují jiné, argumentovatelně reálnější modely šumu, které jsou také uvažovány – a bez ohledu na
zvolený model, pokud se ukáže, že nás náš model zavede na scestí a dozvíme se něco nového o chybách v
systému, se kterým pracujeme, můžeme přirozeně formulovat a uvažovat různé modely chyb – dále si
probereme základní strategii pro implementaci kvantových circuitů odolnou vůči chybám – uvažujme tedy daný
logický kvantový circuit, tedy ideální kvantový circuit, který nás zajímá spustit – například bychom mohli uvažovat stejný circuit jako
dříve, který je nyní trochu roztažen, protože budeme potřebovat trochu více místa pro implementaci odolnou vůči chybám – nejprve
WEBVTT
přípravy stavů, unitární gates a měření nebudou prováděny přímo jako jednotlivé gates nebo jako
jednotlivá měření qubitů nebo přípravy stavů, ale budou prováděny tzv. gadgety, které
mohou každý zahrnovat více qubitů a více operací – tady v tomto diagramu jsem
toto znázornil tak, že jsem tyto věci ohraničil fialovými rámečky – a tyto fialové rámečky si můžeš představit jako malé circuity nebo operace, které jsou
jednoduše pojmenovány podle přípravy stavu nebo gate, který zamýšlíme implementovat – za druhé musíme chránit
qubity pomocí kódu opravujícího chyby – takže to nebudou samotné logické qubity, které tyto různé gadgety propojují, ale gadgety působí na
fyzické qubity, které tyto logické qubity kódují – a stojí za zdůraznění, že logické qubity, o které nám
jde, nikdy nejsou odkryty, což znamená, že tyto logické qubity stráví celý svůj život pod ochranou libovolného
kvantového kódu opravujícího chyby, který používáme – a nakonec provádíme opravu chyb na našich zakódovaných qubitech
opakovaně v průběhu výpočtu, v podstatě kdykoliv máme příležitost – a je kriticky důležité, abychom
toto dělali – intuitivně řečeno, jak nastávají chyby, náhodnost nebo nejistota se začíná hromadit v stavu našich
qubitů a musíme neustále pracovat na odstranění této náhodnosti nebo entropie – a to se děje prostřednictvím opravy chyb
takže si tyto kroky opravy chyb můžeš nějak představit jako malé logické ledničky nebo tepelná čerpadla, která
umožňují logickým qubitům zůstat v chladném stavu, aby výpočet mohl fungovat správně
jakmile jsou provedeny všechny tyto volby, tedy výběr všech gadgetů i kódu, a předpokládá se konkrétní model šumu, existuje
základní otázka, kterou si můžeme položit: skutečně to pomáhá? Děláme věci lepší nebo
je děláme horšími? Pokud je šumu příliš mnoho, mohli bychom věci velmi dobře zhoršovat,
stejně jako 9qubitový Shorův kód věci zhoršuje, pokud je pravděpodobnost chyby příliš vysoká
ale pokud je šum pod určitou prahovou hodnotou, pak nám tato veškerá práce navíc pomůže – a jak budeme diskutovat ke konci lekce,
otevírají se cesty pro další snižování chyb – v této části lekce budeme diskutovat o šíření chyb v
kvantových circuitech odolných vůči chybám se základní strukturou, kterou jsem právě popsal – to se ukazuje být
primárním zájmem, protože pokud se nám nepodaří řídit šíření chyb, chyby rychle přemohou naše úsilí o
opravu chyb – ale pokud jsme schopni řídit šíření chyb, náš kód bude mít mnohem lepší šanci
udržet krok, aby chyby mohly být opravovány dostatečně rychle, a naše výpočty budou
fungovat – výchozím bodem pro tuto diskusi je uvědomění si, že dvoququbitové gates nebo obecněji vícequbitové gates
mohou šířit chyby i tehdy, když fungují správně
například uvažuj C NOT gate – předpokládej, že X chyba nastane na řídicím qubitu před provedením C NOT
X chyba funguje stejně jako X gate – a zjistíme, že
circuit vlevo je ekvivalentní tomu napravo, kde X chyby nastávají na obou qubitech po C
NOT – to je šíření chyb, protože nešťastná poloha X chyby vlevo ji efektivně mění
ve dvě X chyby napravo – a tomu se nikdy nevyhneme – dokud používáme C NOT gates, vždy bude
existovat šance, že X chyba nastane na řídicím qubitu těsně před ním, která se pak rozšíří do dvou X chyb
poté – ale jak uvidíme, pokud podnikneme kroky k omezení škody, którou to způsobuje, bude to v pořádku – a mimochodem
stejný jev nastává, když máme Z chybu na cílovém qubitu těsně před C NOT – a toto jsme
probrali dříve a tyto rovnosti si můžeš ověřit jednoduše provedením násobení nebo pomocí
Qiskit – výsledkem je, že v obou případech to způsobí korelované chyby na více qubitech – a samozřejmě
nesmíme zapomenout, že samotné C NOT gates by mohly být také chybné, což může způsobit korelované
chyby – k naší obavě, následné dvoququbitové gates by mohly tyto chyby dál šířit
například, pokud máme tři C NOT gates takto, jako nacházíme například při měření X stabilizátorových generátorů, pak jedna chyba může
rychle se šířit na více qubitů – a pokud se to stane v jednom bloku kódu, například, tedy skupině
qubitů, které dohromady kódují logický qubit, libovolný kód opravující chyby, který jsme zvolili, nebude mít
šanci, protože kódy jsou navrženy k opravě chyb s nízkými vahami, nikoli takto s vysokými vahami
a to je něco, co musíme mít přední myslí, když přemýšlíme o gadgetech a
krocích opravy chyb v kvantových circuitech odolných vůči chybám – nejjednodušší known způsob, jak zmírnit šíření chyb v
kvantových circuitech odolných vůči chybám, je implementovat gates transversálně a vysvětlím, co to znamená
za chvíli – takže nechme obrázek naší implementace odolné vůči chybám na obrazovce jen jako vizuální pomůcku
myšlenka spočívá v tom, že pro některé kvantové kódy opravující chyby lze určité gates implementovat transversálně,
což znamená jejich implementaci pomocí gadgetů, které jsou tensorovými součiny operací, kde každá operace působí pouze na
jednu pozici qubitu v rámci každého bloku kódu – to nejsnadněji vysvětlím na příkladech – prvním a
arguably nejjednodušším příkladem jsou transversální implementace Pauliho gates
myšlenka spočívá v tom, že chceme vybudovat gadgety pro každý z gates v našem circuitu – a ve všech případech tyto gadgety
pracují na blocích kódu, jak vidíme pro X a Z gates na konci našeho teleportačního circuitu – samozřejmě
nemůžeme dekódovat, aplikovat Pauliho gate a pak znovu zakódovat, protože by to nechalo logický qubit nechráněný a chyby
by se mohly šířit v bloku kódu jako výsledek opětovného kódování
naštěstí to nemusíme dělat, pokud použijeme stabilizátorový kód, protože každý stabilizátorový kód umožňuje Pauliho
operace aplikovat přímo na naše logické qubity – a ve skutečnosti to lze provést tensorovým součinem Pauliho gates
na fyzické qubity použité pro kódování
například, pokud uvažujeme povrchový kód 3x3, který se objevil na konci předchozí lekce, pak můžeme implementovat X a Z gates na logický
qubit zakódovaný tímto kódem tensored-ováním dohromady X a Z gates spolu s identity gates v vzorech, které jsou
naznačeny zde – toto je transversální implementace těchto gates, protože každá z těchto jednotlivých operací gates
působí pouze na jednu pozici qubitu v rámci každého bloku kódu
WEBVTT
zde používáme pouze jednoqubitové gates, takže je to v jistém smyslu triviální, ale každopádně, gadgety jako tento nebudou způsobovat šíření chyb – nyní, jeden z
jednotlivých gates v gadgetu, jako je tento, by mohl selhat, a to zavede
chyby, ale vždy provedeme opravu chyb ihned po každém gadgetu – a pokud je chybovost dostatečně
nízká, kód opravující chyby tyto chyby opraví
a jak jsem řekl, toto je vždy možné pro Pauliho gates pro každý stabilizátorový kód
ačkoli musíš identifikovat správný vzor Pauliho gates v gadgetech, abys správně implementoval jakoukoli logickou Pauliho operaci, o kterou
jde – pro další příklad, který skutečně zahrnuje dvoququbitové gates – tentokrát můžeme uvažovat transversální implementace
C NOT gates – konkrétně, pro každý CSS kód vždy lze implementovat C NOT gate
mezi dvěma logickými qubity jednoduše provedením C NOT gates na odpovídajících párech fyzických
qubitů – a to splňuje podmínku transversálnosti, protože každý z těchto jednotlivých C NOT gates působí pouze
na jednu pozici qubitu v rámci každého bloku kódu – například první C NOT gate působí pouze na nejvyšší qubit
v každém bloku kódu, druhý C NOT gate působí pouze na druhý qubit shora a tak
dále – v tomto případě by mohlo dojít k šíření chyb, protože C NOT gates šíří chyby a neexistuje
způsob, jak tomu zabránit – ale klíčem je, že šíření chyb nikdy nenastane uvnitř jednoho bloku kódu – například,
X chyba by mohla nastat na nejvyšším qubitu nejvyššího bloku kódu těsně před provedením gadgetu a první C NOT
v gadgetu tuto chybu rozšíří na nejvyšší qubit v dolním bloku – ale dvě výsledné chyby jsou
nyní v oddělených blocích kódu – takže kroky opravy chyb, které nastávají po gadgetu, budou schopny tyto chyby opravit nezávisle, protože tyto
chyby postihují pouze jediný qubit v každém bloku kódu
na rozdíl od toho, kdyby šíření chyb nastalo uvnitř stejného bloku kódu, mohli bychom mít problém, protože
šíření chyb pak mění chybu s nízkou vahou na chybu s vyšší vahou, se kterou náš kód nemusí umět zacházet
tato implementace nefunguje pro non-CSS kódy, ale pokud použijeme CSS kód, vždy lze implementovat C NOT
gates transversálně tímto způsobem – a pro ještě jeden příklad, každý
Cliffordův gate lze implementovat transversálně pro Steinův kód – a ve skutečnosti pro jakýkoli barevný kód, což je jedna z opravdu hezkých věcí na barevných
kódech – konkrétně Hadamard gate na logickém qubitu lze implementovat provedením Hadamard gates jednotlivě na
každém z fyzických qubitů, a logický S gate lze implementovat nikoli S gatem na každém qubitu, ale spíše
S dagger gatem na každém fyzickém qubitu – takže výsledkem je, že transversální implementace gates jsou přirozeně
odolné vůči chybám, protože nikdy nešíří chyby uvnitř jednoho bloku kódu, což dává krokům opravy chyb šanci opravit
jakékoli chyby zavedené nebo rozšířené gates použitými pro tyto gadgety – takže to je skvělé a je to
opravdu jednoduchý způsob, jak budovat gadgety odolné vůči chybám, a existují různé kódy umožňující transversální implementace různých gates,
například T gates, ale bohužel je nemožné, aby jakýkoli netriviální kód implementoval
universální sadu gates transversálně, což je fakt known jako Eastin-Knillův teorém – v techničtějších termínech říká,
že pokud náš kód má vzdálenost alespoň dvě, sada gates, které lze implementovat transversálně, bude nutně generovat
diskrétní sadu operací až na globální fázi, a proto tato sada není universální, protože universální sady gates
nutně generují nekonečně mnoho operací – nebudu vysvětlovat důkaz tohoto teorému, který využívá některé
základní fakty o Lieových grupách a Lieových algebrách, které nejsou předpokladem pro tento seriál – ale základní myšlenka je,
že nekonečné rodiny transversálních operací nás nemohou udržet uvnitř kódového prostoru, protože nepatrné
rozdíly v transversálních operacích jsou dobře aproximovány Pauliho operacemi s nízkou vahou, které kód detekuje jako
chyby – takže jsme moc rádi, když dokážeme implementovat gates transversálně – ale pro libovolný kód, který zvolíme, víme, že
vždy budou existovat některé gates, které takto implementovat nemůžeme – a proto musíme hledat alternativní gadgety – díky
Eastin-Knillovu teorému víme, že není možné implementovat universální sadu kvantových gates transversálně ani pro
skromný kód opravující chyby se vzdáleností 2 – musíme tedy najít jiné způsoby, jak implementovat gates odolně
vůči chybám, přinejmenším pro některé gates – jedním well-known způsobem, jak to provést, je použití tzv. magických
stavů – pro účely této diskuse si připomeňme S a T gates, což jsou
jednoqubitové gates definované tak, jak je zobrazeno zde na obrazovce – všimněme si také, že zaprvé S je Cliffordova operace,
což plyne z naší definice Cliffordových operací – ale můžeš si také ověřit, že konjugace Pauliho matice pomocí S vždy dá plus nebo minus jinou
Pauliho matici – a za druhé, T není Cliffordova operace – a ve skutečnosti, pokud zkombinujeme T s Hadamard a C NOT, obojí
jsou Cliffordovy operace, dostaneme universální sadu kvantových gates – takže T gate nemůžeme implementovat
pouze pomocí Cliffordových operací a standardních bázových měření – ale ve skutečnosti T gate implementovat dokážeme pomocí
Cliffordových operací a standardních bázových měření, pokud máme navíc kopii stavu zobrazeného zde na
obrazovce, což je T gate aplikovaný na stav plus
tento stav se nazývá magický stav, ačkoli není v tom ohledu jedinečný
termín magický stav se také používá k označení různých stavů, které plní podobnou roli jako tento v variacích celého tohoto
schématu – například tento circuit zobrazený zde to zvládne – a není příliš obtížné to ověřit
tady je počáteční stav s horním systémem napravo – a pokud aplikujeme C NOT gate a zjednodušíme, dostaneme
stav zobrazený zde
takže pokud změříme dolní qubit a dostaneme nulu, což nastane s pravděpodobností 1/2, neprovádíme
S gate a výstup je T aplikovaný na s
a pokud změříme jedničku, což nastane rovněž s pravděpodobností 1/2, samozřejmě aplikujeme S gate a čistým výsledkem je,
že výstup je opět T aplikovaný na s – to není jediný způsob, jak to udělat, mimochodem – existují jiné podobně vypadající
circuity, které splní stejný úkol, ale je to jeden způsob, jak to provést
toto je poněkud zjednodušený příklad něčeho known jako kvantová teleportace gate, na kterouu jsem narážel zpátky v lekci 4, kde teleportace je použita
WEBVTT
ne k posílání qubitů, ale k aplikování gates – spojitost s teleportací nemusí být zcela jasná, protože, jak jsem
řekl, toto je zjednodušená verze, se kterou se můžeme obejít, protože T je diagonální – ale pokud tě zajímá
dozvědět se více, klíčová slova jsou kvantová teleportace gate
a mohli bychom provést i něco podobného k implementaci S gate, kde tentokrát jediné gates, které potřebujeme, jsou C NOT gate a Z gate spolu s měřením,
což je užitečné, pokud nemáme transversální implementaci S gate – takže to je zajímavé, ale není
zcela jasné, zda nám to skutečně pomáhá – v případě implementace T gate například
se nám daří aplikovat T gate na vstupní stav – ale k tomu, jak se zdá, aplikujeme T gate na stav plus, abychom dostali
magický stav – a situace je podobná pro implementaci S gate – pointa je, že
nemusíme nutně nejprve vytvořit stav plus a pak aplikovat T gate, abychom dostali magický stav – existují jiné možné způsoby, jak tento stav získat – a
konkrétně to lze provést bez nutnosti obávat se šíření chyb v libovolném výpočtu, na kterém pracujeme, protože magické stavy lze vytvořit
odděleně – to umožňuje implementaci T gate odolnou vůči chybám, jak nyní stručně popíši
za prvé, nebudeme skutečně spouštět jednoduchý dvoququbitový circuit zobrazený zde, ale místo toho spustíme tento circuit pomocí
qubitů zakódovaných v libovolném kódu opravujícím chyby, který používáme pro naši implementaci odolnou vůči chybám – to znamená, že
unitární gates a měření jsou prováděny gadgety odolnými vůči chybám – a to také znamená, že potřebujeme naše
magické stavy zakódovat – takže vše bude odolné vůči chybám, pokud se nám podaří dostat zakódované magické stavy do rukou
předpokládáme zde mimochodem, že již máme gadget odolný vůči chybám pro S gate – pokud bychom
například používali Steinův kód, mohli bychom jednoduše implementovat S gate transversálně – a pro kódy, pro které to nefunguje, je jednou možností
nejprve použít celé toto schéma k implementaci S gate odolné vůči chybám a pak tuto implementaci použít zde
ačkoli to není jediná možnost – ale každopádně, vrátím-li se k implementaci, důležitá otázka, která zbývá, je jak se dostaneme ke
zakódovaným magickým stavům, když ještě nemáme implementaci T gate odolnou vůči chybám, abychom to
zjednodušili – a klíčovou myšlenkou je, že můžeme použít pravděpodobnostní proces k vytváření zakódovaných magických stavů – a pokud se to
nestane tak, jak jsme chtěli, to je v pořádku – můžeme jednoduše zahodit jakékoli neúspěšné pokusy a zkusit znovu
a to nenaruší výpočet, který se skutečně snažíme provést, protože vytváření magických stavů se provádí
odděleně – typický způsob, jakým se to dělá, je procesem known jako destilace magických stavů – a funguje to tak
máme určitý circuit known jako destilér – do tohoto destilér přivedeme kolekci hlučných magických
stavů a pak změříme všechny výstupy kromě jednoho – a pokud podmínkujeme na tom, že všechny výsledky měření jsou nula,
pak to, co vyjde, je méně hlučný magický stav, který pak může být jedním z qubitů přivedených do
dalšího destilér – a proces pokračuje, dokud buď neselžeme, protože jeden z výsledků měření je nenulový, a zkusíme znovu, nebo máme magický
stav dostatečně vysoké kvality, abychom ho mohli bezpečně použít k implementaci T gate ve výpočtu, o který nám jde
existují různé known způsoby, jak vybudovat destilér jako tento, ale všechny fungují v podstatě stejně, a sice jsou dekodéry pro stabilizátorové kódy,
což znamená, že jsou invertovány kódovacích circuitů, což je hezké, protože to znamená, že destilér může být Cliffordova
operace – a nakonec, tento destilační proces se ve skutečnosti odehrává na úrovni logického qubitu – takže v realitě je
vše prováděno pomocí gadgetů pro destilér a měření – tento proces musí
někde začít – ale pokud chybovost není příliš vysoká, je možné vytvořit hlučné, ale dostatečně dobré
magické stavy pro jeho spuštění – například aplikací skutečného hlučného T gate na qubit ve stavu plus a pak
zakódováním toho qubitu – takže to byl popis velmi vysoké úrovně, ale doufám, že jsem ti dal hrubou představu, jak to funguje
je to podstatně složitější než implementace gates transversálně, ale přesto nabízí způsob, jak implementovat universální sadu kvantových
gates odolně vůči chybám, zatímco transversální implementace gates to samy o sobě nedokážou – někdy se tvrdí,
že režie pro použití magických stavů k implementaci gates odolně vůči chybám tímto způsobem by byla velmi vysoká
a naprostá většina práce by šla do destilace magických stavů, přičemž spuštění skutečného výpočtu je spíše
vedlejším produktem – ale to vlastně není tak jasné a existují podrobné analýzy, které odhalují, že tato metoda
by mohla být ve skutečnosti praktická – existuje několik dalších known schémat pro implementaci gates odolně vůči chybám – deformace kódů a přepínání kódů jsou názvy
spojené s některými z těchto schémat a nové způsoby se stále vyvíjejí a zdokonalují, ale tato schémata
v této lekci nepopíši – existuje ještě jiný důležitý problém týkající se implementací kvantových circuitů odolných vůči chybám a
týká se samotných kroků opravy chyb – takže nejde o implementaci gates – jde o provedení
skutečné opravy chyb – problémem je, že pokud přemýšlíme o jednoduchých circuitech, které
jsme poprvé viděli v lekci 14 pro měření stabilizátorových generátorů na základě fázové estimace, zjistíme, že nejsou
samy o sobě odolné vůči chybám, protože by mohly potenciálně způsobit šíření chyb uvnitř jednoho bloku kódu
toto se vrací k myšlence, že cokoli zahrnující kvantovou informaci je náchylné k chybám, a to zahrnuje circuity, které jsou samy
určeny k opravě chyb – to se zdá být dost problematické, ale ve skutečnosti existuje více known řešení tohoto problému – zmíním jen několik
z nich, ačkoli žádné z nich podrobně nevysvětlím – a mimochodem, pokud máš dojem, že výpočty odolné vůči chybám jsou
složité a je třeba se starat o spoustu detailů, pak je to pochopitelné, protože je to pravda – je tu spousta pohyblivých částí
a mým záměrem v této lekci není vysvětlit všechny detaily, ale spíše ti poskytnout jen základní úvod do toho, jak to celé
funguje – jedna metoda pro kvantovou opravu chyb odolnou vůči chybám je known jako Shorova oprava chyb, pojmenovaná po Peteru
Shorovi, který tuto metodu navrhl jako první – myšlenka spočívá v provádění každého měření syndromu pomocí tzv. cat stavu,
což je totéž jako GHZ stav, pokud máme tři qubity, ale lze ho zobecnit na libovolný počet qubitů odpovídající váze stabilizátorového
generátoru, který hodláme měřit – konkrétně circuit zobrazený zde funguje pro měření stabilizátorového generátoru – a lze
ukázat, že tato metoda nezpůsobuje šíření chyb uvnitř bloku kódu
vyžaduje vytvoření samotného cat stavu – a aby fungovala spolehlivě v přítomnosti chyb a potenciálně chybných gates, metoda ve skutečnosti
vyžaduje, abychom opakovaně spouštěli takové circuity a vyvozovali závěry o tom, kde mohly nastávat různé chyby v průběhu
procesu – alternativní metoda je known jako Steinova oprava chyb, kterou poprvé navrhl Andrew Stein, a tato
WEBVTT
metoda funguje jinak a funguje pouze pro CSS kódy – v této metodě vlastně neprovádíme měření syndromu na zakódovaných kvantových
stavech v circuitu, který se snažíme spustit, ale místo toho záměrně propagujeme chyby do pracovního systému
a pak tento systém změříme a klasicky detekujeme chyby – tento obrázek zobrazený zde ukazuje, jak to provést pro X chyby, přičemž pracovní
qubity jsou zpočátku nastaveny na kódování stavu plus – takže toto je v podstatě
transversální implementace C NOT gate, která by neměla dělat nic, protože cíl je ve stavu plus – ale pokud by
existovaly X chyby v horních qubitech, rozšíří se do dolního systému a budou detekovány – existuje také podobná metoda pro detekci Z chyb,
která zde není zobrazena – existuje také related metoda known jako Knillova oprava chyb, kterou poprvé navrhl Manny Knill,
a ta je founded na teleportaci spíše než na transversálním C NOT, a to jí umožňuje fungovat pro libovolné stabilizátorové
kódy, nejen pro CSS kódy
poslední věcí, o které budu v této lekci diskutovat, je velmi důležitý teorém known jako věta o prahu – tady je poněkud neformální
formulace věty – říká, že pokud máme libovolný kvantový circuit mající n gates, kde n může být libovolně velké, pak je
možné implementovat tento circuit s vysokou přesností pomocí hlučného kvantového circuitu za předpokladu, že úroveň šumu
je pod určitou prahovou hodnotou, která je nezávislá na n – a navíc, není příliš nákladné to provést v
tom smyslu, že velikost potřebného hlučného circuitu je řádu n násobených určitou konstantní mocninou logaritmu
n – k formálnímu formulování věty je třeba být specifický ohledně modelu šumu, což v této lekci nebudu dělat
může být například dokázáno pro model nezávislého stochastického šumu, který jsem zmínil dříve, kde chyby nastávají
nezávisle na každém možném místě v circuitu s určitou pravděpodobností, která je přísně menší než tato prahová hodnota – ale může být také
dokázáno pro obecnější modely šumu, kde mohou existovat korelace mezi chybami – nyní je to teoretický
výsledek a typický způsob, jakým se dokazuje, se nemusí nutně překládat do něčeho, co bychom skutečně dělali v praxi, ale přesto je to velmi
důležitý teorém z praktického hlediska – a důvod pro to je, že v podstatě říká, že neexistuje žádná základní překážka pro provádění
kvantových výpočtů pomocí hlučných komponent
pokud je chybovost těchto komponent pod touto prahovou hodnotou, mohou být použity k budování spolehlivých kvantových circuitů libovolné
velikosti – jiný způsob, jak to říct, je, že pokud by věta nebyla pravdivá, je těžké si představit, že by se rozsáhlé kvantové výpočty
kdy staly realitou – v formálních důkazech tohoto teorému je zahrnuto mnoho technických detailů, o které se nebudu pokoušet
komunikovat – ale pokusím se vysvětlit základní myšlenku na vysoké úrovni – a pokusím se volně propojit základní
myšlenku s tím, co bychom mohli očekávat v praxi – předpokládejme tedy, že toto je náš circuit – je to stejný circuit, o kterém
jsme mluvili po celou lekci – ale opět si můžeme představit, že náš circuit je výrazně větší a složitější než tento – chceme
implementovat tento circuit, ale všechny naše komponenty jsou hlučné – a za předpokladu, že používáme model nezávislého stochastického šumu
jen pro jednoduchost, existuje určitá pravděpodobnost P, s níž chyby nastávají nezávisle na každém možném místě
pokud by byl circuit výrazně větší než reciproká hodnota této pravděpodobnosti P, mohli bychom si být poměrně jisti, že
přímá implementace by nefungovala správně – takže projdeme celým procesem implementace circuitu
odolně vůči chybám, jak jsem diskutoval až do tohoto bodu v lekci, a položíme si otázku, kterou jsem položil dříve: děláme věci
lepší nebo je děláme horšími? no, pokud pravděpodobnost P, která reprezentuje pravděpodobnost chyby pro každou z našich komponent, je příliš velká, pak
nám to nepomůže, stejně jako 9qubitový Shorův kód nepomáhá, pokud je pravděpodobnost chyby nad asi 3 a čtvrt procent
konkrétně jsme nyní circuit zvětšili – takže existuje mnohem více míst, kde by mohly chyby zasáhnout
pokud je ale P dostatečně malé, pomůže nám to – a to, co efektivně uděláme, je snížení pravděpodobnosti chyby
pro logický výpočet, který provádíme – zamysleme se nad tím trochu
více do detailu – a abychom viděli hlavní myšlenky v co nejjednodušším nastavení, předpokládejme, že používáme 7qubitový Steinův kód pro opravu
chyb, který umožňuje opravu nejvýše jedné chyby za blok kódu – takže aby nastala logická chyba
v původním circuitu, musíme mít alespoň dvě chyby, které spadají do stejného bloku kódu pro naši odolnou
implementaci
s přihlédnutím k tomu, že existuje mnoho různých způsobů, jak mít dvě nebo více chyb ve stejném bloku kódu, lze argumentovat, že pravděpodobnost logické
chyby na každém místě v původním circuitu je nejvýše C * P ^ 2, kde C je číslo, které závisí na kódu a na
gadgetech, které používáme – ale kriticky, nezávisí na velikosti původního circuitu
takže pokud je P menší než reciproká hodnota C, což je číslo, které můžeme vzít jako naši prahovou hodnotu, pak to
vede ke snížení chyb – takže naše tvrdá práce při implementaci circuitu odolně vůči chybám se vyplácí
tato nová chybovost však stále může být příliš vysoká, aby celý circuit fungoval správně – takže musíme dělat
více – v praxi je přirozenou věcí v tuto chvíli zvolit lepší kód a lepší gadgety, aby se chybovost snížila
na bod, kde je implementace pravděpodobně funkční
teoreticky, jednoduchý způsob, jak argumentovat, že je to možné, je zřetězení – jinými slovy,
přemýšlíme o implementaci původního circuitu odolné vůči chybám jako o novém logickém circuitu – a pak ho implementujeme odolně
vůči chybám – a pak to děláme znovu a znovu, tolikrát, kolikrát potřebujeme – a ukazuje se, že to snižuje chyby
velmi rychle – a tak se věta o prahu typicky dokazuje na papíře
dám ti jen velmi přibližnou představu o tom, jak se chybovost snižuje, přičemž vynechám mnoho technických detailů potřebných k
formálnímu dokázání tohoto – začínáme s pravděpodobností chyby P pro naše původní komponenty – a pokud implementujeme
circuit odolně vůči chybám, chyba se sníží o faktor C * P – pokud pak naši implementaci odolnou vůči chybám
považujeme za logický circuit a implementujeme ji odolně vůči chybám, dostaneme podobné snížení chybovosti – ale
pokud přemýšlíme o efektivní chybovosti pro původní circuit, zjistíme, že klesá ještě dál, protože nyní
nahrazujeme chybovost P hodnotou C * P ^ 2, protože to je efektivní chybovost po první úrovni odolné
implementaci – konkrétně, po trochu algebry, zjistíme, že chyba klesá na CP na třetí násobenou P – a pokud
to uděláme znovu, máme nyní chybovost CP ^ 7 násobená P – a pokud
WEBVTT
to budeme dělat celkem K úrovní, zjistíme, že chyba se zmenšuje dvojitě exponenciálně v K – takže
není třeba to dělat příliš mnohokrát, aby se chybovost stala extrémně malou
mezitím circuity rostou na velikosti, ale velikost se zvyšuje pouze jednoduše exponenciálně v K, protože s každou
úrovní odolnosti vůči chybám roste velikost našeho circuitu nejvýše o faktor, který je dán maximální velikostí
našich gadgetů – a když se to vše dá dohromady a provede se vhodná volba počtu
úrovní zřetězení, dostaneme větu o prahu – ale jak jsem již naznačil, k formálnímu dokázání tohoto je třeba mnoho detailů – takže
jaká je tato prahová hodnota v realitě? no, závisí na kódu a na gadgetech, které
používáme – pro Steinův kód spolu s destilací magických stavů je nepatrná a pravděpodobně v praxi nedosažitelná
– ale pomocí povrchových kódů a nejmodernějších gadgetů se odhaduje, že je přibližně 1 % – což není
špatné – a jak jsou objevovány nové kódy a metody, můžeme rozumně očekávat, že se bude zvyšovat, zatímco současně
úroveň šumu v komponentách, které budujeme, se bude snižovat – dosáhnout bodu, ve kterém
rozsáhlé kvantové výpočty mohou být implementovány odolně vůči chybám, nebude snadné a nestane se to přes noc
ale tento teorém spolu s pokroky v kvantových kódech a kvantovém hardwaru, které jsme dosud zaznamenali,
nám poskytuje optimismus, který potřebujeme, abychom pokračovali v tlaku vpřed k dosažení tohoto konečného cíle budování
rozsáhlého kvantového počítače odolného vůči chybám – a to je konec lekce a konec série –
upřímně doufám, že jsi v seriálu našel hodnotu, a pokud ano, zvažte prosím jeho doporučení kolegovi nebo příteli
nezapomeň se také podívat na IBM Quantum Learning pro další kurzy a tutoriály a přihlásit se k odběru Qiskit
YouTube kanálu, pokud jsi to ještě neudělal, abyste mohli zůstat aktuální s budoucími vydáními obsahu – děkuji za
sledování